[Music]
so the second grade on truth is always
trust your feelings the wisdom
traditions of the entire world say don't
do that
for example some of the quotes we have
in the book from Shakespeare there's
nothing good or bad but thinking makes
it so
from Marcus Aurelius the whole world is
change and life itself is but what you
deem it from Buddha our thoughts are the
creations of our minds with our minds we
make the world cbt is just a way of
teaching people skills to do exactly
that to question their feelings to look
for evidence
so in CBT you learn the names of these
distortions about 15 or so distortions
you can guess what they mean
catastrophizing black and white thinking
labeling mind reading these are the
things that depressed and anxious people
do a lot one way to sort of keep you
know if all of us have had experiences
these one thing I like to think about is
Homer Simpson saying shut up brain or
I'll stab you with a q-tip our brains do
this
our brains go on and on but like to stop
it stop it stop it well CBT is a way of
stopping it it's so easy to learn many
people including me learned it from a
wonderful book by David Burns called
feeling good in our book we and on our
webpage if you go to the codling org we
have suggestions for books and apps
where you can learn it cognitive
behavioral therapy is not more effective
than several other treatments there are
most treatments are about equally
effective but it's so easy to learn if
you teach and I've done this in my
classes if you assign everyone in the
class to learn CBT most people get it
and get something out of it other
techniques like meditation work but
they're harder most people drop off so
CBT is easy really well tested has a
huge impact on a variety of mental and
mountain mental illnesses especially
those related to depression and anxiety
we think every college student and tech
every high school student should be
taught these basic skills given how high
the rates of anxiety and depression are
today so for the last few years we've
been hearing reports that counseling
centers on campus are overwhelmed we're
hearing stories about rising depression
and anxiety
some people say oh it's nothing to be
alarmed about it's not real it's just
that young people today they're so
comfortable talking about mental illness
they're more open about it and that's
why the rates seemed to be rising sounds
plausible not true
it's not just that young people are more
comfortable we know this because studies
have been done looking at hospital
admission data who is being admitted to
hospitals because they cut themselves
they took poison they harmed themselves
in some other way we see exactly the
same curves on that date in particular
boys are not changing but girls are
going way way up only teenage girls not
Millennials not kids born before 1995
but kids born in 1995 and after the
girls in particular are cutting
themselves and being admitted to
hospitals and much higher rates most
alarmingly the suicide rate if you look
at the last couple years compared to the
first ten years of the century the
suicide rate for American boys teenage
boys is up 25% which is a gigantic
increase the suicide rate for American
girls is up 70% so something is going
wrong something is affecting American
teenagers especially girls so in the
United States right now as many people
have noticed we are we are seeing a huge
escalation of our long-running culture
war unfortunately universities are right
in the heart of that the right loves to
come in and say the university is our
bastions of political correctness
they've lost their minds the left is
motivated to say no there's no not a
problem there's nothing going on it's
just that the right hates ideas they
hate universities so the way that this
whole book started is that Gregg
lukianov my co-author and friend is
prone to depression and he had a
suicidal depression in 2007 he was
hospitalized and he learned cognitive
behavioral therapy as part of his
treatment and he credits it with saving
his life so he goes back to his job as
the president of the foundation for
individual rights and education he's
been fighting for free speech rights for
students pushing back against
administrators who are always imposing
speech limits students were always his
best supporters students
we wanted the rights to speak and think
and be independent until 2013 beginning
in the fall of 2013 he started seeing
the first cases of students saying we
want protections from words books ideas
speakers we want speakers disinvited
don't let this person onto our campus
not because it will be offensive but
because it will be dangerous it will be
harmful it will be traumatizing we want
trigger warnings if you're going to
assign a book that has violence in it
especially sexual violence like a Greek
myth which has rape if you're going to
sign that you need to warn students
against it
so that they can choose whether they
want to have sent themselves on that day
so this was something new and at first
it was just a strange thing at a few
schools and then over the following year
it built to the point where in 2014 we
started reading articles in the New
Republic in The New York Times about
trigger warnings safe spaces
microaggression training bias response
teams a whole set of constructs and
procedures emerged on certain
universities not everywhere but
especially at elite schools in the
Northeast and on the west coast a way of
protecting students from words books
ideas and speakers speakers were shouted
down increasingly not because they were
offensive and hateful but because they
were dangerous for students to think
about ideas in terms of right or wrong
is great exciting versus boring is great
but safe versus dangerous this is a
terrible way to approach the
intellectual world so Greg came to talk
to me because what he saw was students
doing the exact cognitive distortions
that he had learned to stop doing when
he was treated for cognitive behavioral
therapy when he's treated for depression
greg was concerned that if students are
beginning to think this way about safety
and danger and harmfulness that this is
gonna make them depressed and anxious
and that's what led us to write our
original article in the in the Atlantic
in 2015
titled the coddling of the American mind
we published the article in 2015 before
a big wave of student protests in around
Halloween of 2015 so these these trends
that we saw that Greg and I both saw
hints of in 2014 they exploded in the
fall of 2015
they've spread much more widely in the
couple years since then and at the same
time we're seeing rates of depression
and anxiety increasing rapidly - we're
not saying these are causing that we
don't know but there is a national wave
of depression students are thinking in
terms of safety and danger students say
by their own admission they are more
fragile they use a language of fragility
weakness trauma triggering they see
triggers all over the world
what are triggers triggers are cases
where you take a part of your nervous
system and you say if someone says that
word they can control my nervous system
and make me afraid and anxious that's a
terrible idea we should not be teaching
our kids - to see the world as being
full of triggers we should teach them to
live in a world that is physically quite
safe but full of offensive statements
and ideas especially on the Internet a
sad commentary on the state of the
business world now is that Google is
being sued from both sides from women
who say that they're victims of a
hostile climate and from conservatives
and white men who say that conservatives
and white men are discriminated against
so when our current era everybody feels
they're a victim the truth is that
diversity of perspectives is essential
for healthy organizations especially
those who care about innovation we have
to address all of the diversity issues
at the same time we can't pit them
against each other we have to work on
our speech climate in the business world
is called Speak Up culture in the
academic world that's called just basic
openness to ideas we're having problems
all across American society we got to
work on them
[Music]